[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATIE RICHARDSON: For all
of our certifications,
we list out a preparation path
on our certification pages.
I think that focuses
primarily on what
are the trainings, what are the
resources that we can give you.
We give some recommendations
for hands-on labs.
We also recommend using the
GCP free tier or any resources
that we have to get you
into the products and tools
that you'll be assessed on.
I think if you, in
addition to that,
need some additional
professional experience, what
we recommend is just using the
exam guide to see what topics
are going to be
assessed and kind
of doing a self-evaluation.
Make sure that you're
there with those skills.
And it might mean
that you should
wait six months or
a year while you
are getting those
additional skills before you
attempt the exam.
But using the exam guides
and those resources kind of
helps you set that benchmark.
It helps you know
where you're at so
that then you can
prepare better as you're
looking at certification.